jamais une consultation sur le site du
CNA a eu autant de participants
puisqu'on était à plus de 51300
participants à cette consultation donc
on voit que les réponses ont été
particulièrement nombreuses que les
personnes qui ont répondu s'intéressent
au sujet puisque 97 % des personnes qui
ont répondu savent ce qu'est une ZFE et
puis on a des enseignements attirés par
rapport à ces chiffres 86% des personnes
se déclarent défavorables à
l'instauration des AFE et donc 69% très
défavorables donc il est évident qu'à
travers ces chiffres on peut voir que
cette mesure n'est pas pour l'instant
comprise par nos concitoyens on a fait
analyser ces chiffres de manière très
précise par un spécialiste un expert des
données qui attiré un certain nombre
d'enseignements et de corrélations on
est moins favorable aux ZFE quand on vit
à l'extérieur des élèves on est moins
favorables aux ZFE quand on est ouvrier
ou retraité à la différence les chiffres
qui sont un petit peu supérieur mais qui
reste quand même négatif par rapport à
la moyenne on est un petit peu plus
favorable aux LFE quand on est étudiant
ou quand on est cadre et quand on habite
au sein de ces ZF et puis surtout les
chiffres intéressants à travers les
questions ouvertes qui ont été proposées
c'est d'expliquer pourquoi les personnes
étaient défavorables aux élèves donc
elles expliquent premièrement c'est la
principale raison que l'acquisition de
véhicules électriques reste encore trop
cher avec un reste à financer trop
important la deuxième
explication qui est donnée c'est que
quand on habite en dehors des élèves eux
l'accès au métropole est compliquée
parce qu'il n'y a pas suffisamment de
transport en commun en fin dernier point
il est clairement exprimé également par
les personnes qui ont répondu à cette
consultation qu'il y a besoin de temps
et que la précipitation fait qu'il ne
n'accepte pas encore ses décisions
nous avons auditionné pratiquement une
centaine de personnes nous avons fait
des déplacements sur le terrain il y a
d'autres
points qui vont rentrer en ligne de
compte sur les conclusions mais il
paraît évident qu'il y a un vrai
problème d'information il y a un
problème de synchronisation entre le
calendrier des élèves les schémas de
restriction et les mesures que prennent
aujourd'hui les pouvoirs publics pour
plus de transports en commun pour un
accompagnement pour des aides il y a un
véritable décalage il y a un problème
d'harmonisation aussi parce que on va
dans les années à venir avoir
pratiquement 43 ZF avec 43 règles
différentes donc il est évident que
quand les ZF eux sont très proches les
unes des autres dans certaines régions
il faut les harmoniser enfin il faut
peut-être avoir sur certains points sur
certaines décisions quelque chose qui ne
tombe pas comme un coup près mais qui
soit plus individualisé en fonction de
je dirais de l'entretien qu'on apporte
ou non à son véhicule quel que soit son
âge et quel que soit le type de
motorisation
[Musique]